so I following very interesting speakers
today
and when I was asked to speak for a seat
bar he has an on-the-ground worker I
felt this was a very daunting task for
me I've taken much time and effort to
write a very well-written and curated
speech and when I realized this morning
that I couldn't remember a word of it I
made a very conscious choice and this
speech is getting put down because the
most important thing about today is
everybody in this room sharing their
experiences and what I'd like to do
today is share my story and share my
experience I don't have data to back me
up I don't have years and years of
wisdom and accumulated research that's
going to prove what I do is right but
what I do is I get to experience
everyday the light and children's eyes
as they give back to the world so I'll
start with my story and it actually
starts with me as a child and when I was
seven years old my father started
instilling giving in me and we've
already heard questions to Laura today
about you know when can you start
Laura started at the age of two with
children and and trying to understand
that giving in my family it was a
tradition my father was a doctor my
mother was a nurse and so they instilled
in us and every Christmas is my first
memory and my father would pack us all
up we put on your nice little Christmas
outfits I think mine was a reindeer
outfit and he'd take us down to the
hospital that he worked you know my
father's office never closed he worked
in a hospital it was open 24/7 and he
worked 24/7 but on Christmas Day he
didn't have to work he went into the
hospital because he chose to because his
patients were stuck in their rooms those
little rooms with dark settings they
didn't get to go home to the traditions
of family Christmases and so he brought
us along to give them a little injection
of Christmas
into the rooms and so we would stand
around at the edge of their beds and we
would start singing we wish you a Merry
Christmas and what I realized as I stood
there is you could actually see the
light in the patients faces you could
almost see the late in their hearts as
we sang away and we gave them this
little injection this little gift that
made their day a little bit better it
was my first act of volunteerism I had
the opportunity to give of my time on
Christmas Day with my family
and give a gift to somebody in need and
I realized something about that even at
the age of 7 it made me happy
giving actually made me happy even that
so move forward in time I get a little
older I can't continue doing my giving
with my family throughout my childhood
and I come into my 20s and I say okay
I've got the world at my feet it's an
open open oyster I can choose whatever I
want to do with my world and I had no
idea what I wanted to do I could become
a doctor like my father and nurse like
my mother but the one message that had
been driven back to me all of the time
was do something for a living that made
you happy well I kept going back to it I
realize the one thing that always made
me happy throughout my childhood was
giving so off I went and I started a
career on giving I became a special
event fund raiser and as you heard
earlier I had the opportunity to work
with some amazing people people just
like you in this room you're on the
ground workers you work in collaboration
with other people to do some good in our
world and so that's what I did and I
worked away as a special event fund
raiser for a number of decades and I
realized something in my journey that
every hour that I worked that I knew was
benefiting somebody else or a different
cause or a different organization it
continued to make me happy through the
years we've heard
a lot about the research that has been
going on with these two amazing people
today and the National Institute of
research talks about something called
the helpers hi I don't know if anybody
has actually heard about it here but we
have this little part in our brain our
prefrontal cortex of our brain and it's
actually been proven via MRI studies as
they watch the brain that even just by
thinking about altruism your brain is
activated it's activated in the same way
that you do through sex
recreational recreational drugs large
activity some of you may have heard of
the runner's high and in my case you
know a triple-layer chocolate fudge cake
which you know happens to be also food
but giving actually stimulates that same
part of your brain that gives you what
they refer to as the helpers hi so my
life moves forward and I'm given in a
remarkable gift one day I get a call and
I've become a mom pretty unusual not the
way most people you know become a mother
but my husband and I had decided that we
had wanted to adopt a child and that
call came one day and very shortly
afterwards I had the opportunity for the
very first time to hold this 11 week old
boy in my arms and that's when my world
truly changed forever that little boy
inspired me so much that I knew I had to
make the world a better place I don't
know how I was gonna do it I already
kind of thought I had done a lot through
my career but I realized I needed to
make the world a better place for him
and the other children of the world I
also knew as a parent that I wanted to
instill the same values in my child that
my parents had instilled in me I wanted
him to be kind I wanted him to be
compassionate I wanted to I wanted him
to experience what I had experienced and
was I wanted him to be happy and learn
it through acts of giving so at the ripe
old age of three I thought my son was
ready to learn to give I gave him a gift
on his third birthday and no it was not
a shiny new red bike I decided to start
a journey with him a journey of giving
every day for 365 days we committed to
doing one thing to give back to the
world
aka 365 gift I decided that to record
our journey I was gonna start a blog cuz
that's what everybody did at that time
just so you're very clear I'm not a
writer I'd never done social media I
wasn't on Facebook I had never done
Twitter but I decided that our journey
was so important to me that I wanted to
share it with as many people as I could
so every day I would get every day I
would blog and for 365 days that's what
we did we gave back and an amazing thing
happened surprisingly people read the
blog people actually engaged with
Twitter and Facebook they emailed us
from all over the world one of my
favorite stories and and comments that I
got back her email that I got was
actually from a teacher in Australia and
she emailed me one day she said you know
I've been following your blog I've been
following your journey she said and I've
actually now taken 365 give and I've put
it into my classroom this email
literally put me to tears I was amazed
that what my son and I were doing
together was actually inspiring a
teacher on the other side of the world
to teach her students to give as our
journey unfolded and actually came close
to an end I realized that our daily
giving had almost become an addiction
for me actually my husband would for
sure say it had become an addiction for
me but what I really
realized as we completed our journey was
that it gave my son and I a chance to
connect to our community it connected us
to other places around the world and
most of all our giving made us happy
together so an amazing thing happened on
day 365 as you heard earlier my husband
and I had been in the process of
adopting our second child throughout
this journey and on day 365 my son's
fourth birthday
my second son came home amazing well as
we said earlier imagine what you give
because the gifts may keep coming back
and bang
six months later my third son came home
well for a short time after that I was a
little bit busy in my world I was trying
to just get through the personal torture
of sleep deprivation having two little
boys under the age of one at the time
and one still not quite of the age of
five but I knew that I was still
committed to 360 365 give I knew that
one day I would find a way to take what
we did and transition it to another part
of the world I knew I still wanted to
give back to the world in some way
well year and a half into my motherhood
journey I was given the opportunity to
do just that I got a call from a friend
of mine her name Sarah Danaher and she
too was a mom and she was also a teacher
at a local school in west vancouver
pauline johnson french immersion school
and sarah said you know can we get
together i want to chat about something
and so we did what moms do we had a
playdate and we're down at a local beach
in West Vancouver our kids are happily
playing and Sarah says to me I want to
teach my kids what you taught your son
she knew and she had followed the blog
and she had followed our journey and she
had been an amazing supporter and she
felt that what my son and I had done
together was so important she wanted to
instill it in her stay
I was not only honored but humbled I was
excited and I was enthusiastic to see
where this might take us was it actually
even possible to take what we did and
put it into a classroom other than then
Sarah would there be any other teachers
that would even possibly consider this
so we sat down we did our research we
looked at the science of giving we
looked at the psychology of giving it's
actually how Laura and I'm met a number
of years ago we studied how we might be
able to take everyday giving and tie it
into the prescribed outcomes that
teachers have to attain in school with
their students and curricular outcomes
so we could tie daily giving directly
into their curriculum we took what we
thought was a pretty good pilot project
and we took it to her principal we sat
down with her a woman by the name of
Chantal Trudeau who happens to now be
the chair of my board of directors for
365 give and we told her about our pilot
program which we were going to name the
365 give challenge it happens to be a
really interesting tie-in with our
earlier talks on on competition and
challenging our students we were
actually doing something right which I'm
happy to hear we call that the 365 give
challenge and it went to our first goals
in our first 12-week pilot of the
program we had 300 students from the
ages of 5 starting at kindergarten up to
grade 7 they did it they went back their
teachers went back and they Kent started
to give and amazing things happened as
we watched their journey they got
engaged with their learning they were
happy to come to school because it was
their 365 give week at school their
teachers empowered them to choose what
they were gonna do to give back they
weren't told they had to donate to a
charity they weren't told
they had to volunteer the kids and the
teacher sat together and the kids got to
choose exactly what they wanted you
every day for five days so one week of
school one classroom together say the
least when the stories of the giving
started coming out of the school
we were amazingly surprised they help
support the SPCA
they volunteered their time at the local
Senior Center they picked up the garbage
on the beach and it continued one of my
favorite stories is in for day one the
100th day of school at the elementary
level they actually celebrate this day
in school especially at the elementary
level because it gives them an
opportunity to work with math with the
kids and so a grade two class who at
that point in that stage in your you
know your educational career you're just
learning to count to 100 so they decided
that they were gonna tie in the hottest
day of school to their daily gift they
wanted to make 100 dog biscuits to
donate to the local SPCA great idea so
as a parent I look at it both sides and
I'm like fantastic you know the kids are
learning to give but how is this
possibly tying into their education
aren't these kids supposed to be
learning math and science and how to
read and how to write
it's things we worried about all the
time so this is how it worked for the
kids they had to go into research and
find a recipe which they had to read so
they can learn how to make the dog
biscuits in comes they're reading and
writing and research skills even at the
age even in grade two then they had to
mix they did this right in school they
actually had to mix the batter to make
the cookies it tied right into their
science and they learned how baking and
food and science all connect together
they bake their biscuits well they had
to find out how many biscuits they
actually baked here's the neat thing
their goal was a hundred biscuits well
that day that grade two class they
exceeded their own expectations not only
did they
bake a hundred dog biscuits they
actually learned how to count to 212
that day because that's how many dog
biscuits they made which they donated to
the SPCA the stories haven't stopped
they keep coming last year we had 3000
students participate in the 365 gift
challenge 25 schools across the
Vancouver area it it now ranges from the
age of five to the ages of eighteen
student leadership programs are now
embracing it and they are teaching their
younger kids how to give as well one of
my other favorite stories is actually
about a kindergarten class so these are
five-year-olds their teacher their
teacher was teaching them about wildlife
and the ocean and she decided that she
would be able to intertwine their daily
giving and the kids decided that they
wanted to give back somehow to the
wildlife that live in the ocean so they
did a little bit more research and they
discovered that the aquarium had
recently taken in a sea otter by the
name of Wally Wally had been a very sick
sea otter and the aquarium took him in
because he could no longer survive out
in the wild and they brought him back to
health well these little five-year-olds
decided they were going to put on a
fundraiser for school they made posters
with pitchers they got on the school
announcements and started announcing
their fundraising initiative and they
were asked by their teacher to go home
and not ask their parents for money my
kids asked me for money all the time to
bring it a school they were actually
asked to go and do some work around the
house to earn the money so that the
donation was actually coming directly
from them with money that they had
earned well these little kindergarten
kids ended up raising $300 for the
aquarium I was so impressed I called the
aquarium myself and said I got to tell
you about these kids they're they're
amazing they've just raised three
hundred dollars for you and the aquarium
was thrilled they instantly sent bus
loads buses down to the school the next
week they picked up the children and
their teachers and they took them down
to the aquarium so that the kids
themselves could present their donation
right at the aquarium something for
everybody in this room to think about
because I know there is a number of
people here asking those questions for
themselves you know how do we engage new
people how do we get donations from
different types of people across
different borders
well the aquarium saw the opportunity
they saw the opportunity to engage a new
generation of givers that had the
potential of lasting an entire lifetime
so even though our children were
participating in the 365 gift challenge
and they did this particular donation
because of the 365 gift challenge a
really interesting thing happened that
summer and I actually got at via a blog
from the aquarium five of the kids from
that kindergarten class had birthdays at
summer and in lieu of receiving birthday
gifts when they had their birthday
parties they all asked for donations to
give to the aquarium to support Molly
even more between those birthday parties
those children not asked by their
teachers not asked by me
those children raised another additional
$400 for the aquarium so almost 800
dollars went to the aquarium by these
five years olds it was an amazing story
and the benefit that I get is that I get
to sit with these children I get to hear
their stories I get to see the smiles on
their face and they tell me the same
message over and over and over again
giving makes them happy I don't even
have to ask them they're not rewarded
for what they do they have found the
reward in the impact they make with
everybody that they touch and they have
now learned what I learned from my
father is that giving makes them happy
and I can only hope that they will carry
this lesson through their lifetime if
you can take away anything today I
challenge you to find the helpers hi I
challenge you today when you leave find
a way to give in your world
make it simple it can be simple pick up
the garbage that you walk past on the
street put it in the garbage help the
planet today the food bank was raising
money via a market out front go and
support before you go today find the
ways in your life that you can give
because I guarantee you you will get the
happiness back tenfold thank you so much
for having me today
[Applause]